at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by
the genius Finn's who lit the internet
on fire and you may have heard of their
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which has taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or the chugga
which is decaf as a separate version and
I use both of these primarily for focus
and productivity they just get you going
let you up like a Christmas tree so
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect get a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's force
maduk fo you are SI GMA TI c comm
forward slash tim and use the code tim
TI m to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed it's a
trauma this episode is brought to you by
fresh books fresh books has become the
go-to cloud accounting software for
literally millions of small business
owners who found a faster more efficient
and much less stressful way to deal with
their numbers and ultimately this helps
you to focus on what you are best at it
is used by many of the fastest growing
startups I've invested in or advise and
it's equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast their new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things tracking your time the quick
proposals that I mentioned formatting
free super easy late payment reminders
so you don't have to chase people
automatic expenses sharing files and
messages with your clients award-winning
customer service they are extremely
responsive the interface is super
intuitive and there's almost no learning
curve so in short it's easy it saves you
time and right now fresh books is
offering an unrestricted 30-day free
trial for all of my listeners to claim
yours check it out go to FreshBooks
dot-com forward slash tim and enter tim
ferriss in the how did you hear about a
section and that is funky spell t IM e
RR is s so again go to fresh books comm
forward slash tim and enter tim ferriss
and how did you hear about us section
check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this episode is a
special episode I have two people seated
right around me and we are going to
delve into what thousands maybe tens or
hundreds of thousands of you asked for
which our case studies related to
perhaps what some of you might recognize
as muses or startup businesses very
often bootstrapped not necessarily the
venture-backed variety and we have like
I mentioned two people who will be
joining me we have first Elaine Poe felt
silent D P o fel DT who is a journalist
and the author of the million dollar
one-person business thank you so much
for being here
it's my pleasure Tim thank you and
Elaine and I have got to know each other
over the last few years as she has
profiled many people who have started
businesses in many different contexts
and a fair number of them have been
readers of or somehow inspired by
tactically or philosophically by the
4-hour workweek which is how we well I
suppose we first connected ages ago when
the first book came out so this this
goes back some distance it goes back 10
years in fact I was telling you earlier
that when I worked at fortune small
business magazine one of my duties was
as the book editor and I received a lot
of submissions for books to excerpt and
your book was the only one I ever
excerpted because a lot of the other
business books were not up to snuff and
that was how we initially connected so
it's been and I so much appreciate that
because back in the day of course with
an initial print run of whatever was ten
thousand copies twelve thousand copies
it didn't even have national
distribution so he the fledgling
'hatchling days were really really a
sensitive time that could have been an
inflection point when she ended up being
or it could have been crickets
so I appreciate the early support and
then we also have with us today Alan
Walden Alan welcome to the show thanks
for having me and we are going to be
delving into
your story and Alan was introduced to me
by Elaine and Alan is the founder of spy
guy one word capital s capital G spy guy
which is an online security store based
in the Dallas Texas area
Alan xxx currently 30 30 years old
learned the spy camera business while
working in a store that sold spy cameras
for $11 an hour and we will be getting
into some of the backstory and there's
the next line is what I'm gonna probably
dig into first after getting frustrated
with the world of traditional jobs he
used what he learned in the store to
create his own online shop and got to 1
million dollars in run-rate before he
hired any employees or before turning 30
and along the way you found yourself in
all sorts of interesting situations from
spouses who need his help in catching a
cheating mate to helping the police stop
a child predator and the business just
keeps on growing you now have five
employees so once again Alan thanks for
taking the time yeah absolutely so let's
talk about this getting frustrated with
the world of traditional jobs I think
this is a a common sentiment among lots
of people listening probably and could
you tell us a little bit about that
portion of your story yeah so overworked
and underappreciated I guess it's the
term to use I was working in a retail
store that sold surveillance equipment I
was the only employee at the location so
if the store was empty and it was around
like 2:00 p.m. I'd have to hustle
outside the building to grab lunch real
quick and come back because if customers
were to come in and there's nobody there
to help them they could just you know
take everything in the store so it was
just me and I was constantly having to
monitor inventory levels which they
never gave me enough product to keep in
stock so I'd always have to drive for
like a half hour to where the where the
headquarters was and pick up inventory
and load it into my car and then bring
it back to the store so these were like
really long hours I'd have to do that
after my shift ended at like 7 p.m. and
so it'd be 10 p.m. by the time I get
back and it was just a big mess
a little nurse you're good you're good
and this this is this is exactly what I
would say this is the biggest
unscratched itch of people who listen to
this podcast so I'm really happy ur here
and I can't wait to learn more about
your story because I'm coming in as
fresh as possible I have the bare
minimum necessary for guys at all to
pique my interest and there you are
driving around trying to steal a
sandwich in between visitors so that has
disaster does not befall this
establishment or get you fired when did
you start thinking about starting your
own business and why how did that come
about so this is where we kind of get
into that job I had in between starting
spy-guy and then working in the retail
store basically I had this opportunity
that came up through a customer of mine
they were a detective for a TV show
called cheaters and it came at the
perfect moment I was very stressed out
with my employer and just life in
general I guess and I remember this
customer coming into my store and saying
hey my boss wants to meet with you and
he's the guy that created the TV show
cheaters yeah they took me out to lunch
and it turned out that a lot of people
who watched the TV show we're calling in
because they suspected that they had a
boyfriend a girlfriend or spouse that
was having an affair and so they'd want
the TV should have come in and
investigate it and they don't have the
resources to handle that many calls so
they had the bright idea of opening up
an online security store which is what I
knew about and they wanted to sell
hidden cameras GPS trackers covert audio
phone monitoring software all sorts of
surveillance equipment and so I created
that store for them and that lasted for
about three years before I decided that
I really wanted to work for myself and I
did all
the exercises and 4-hour workweek and
ended up leaving in 2014 and starting
spy-guy how did how did the and don't
worry people are listening I'm not gonna
turn this into an infomercial for
workweek but I having come across so
many different stories there are many
different ways that people we get to the
book how did you or have it get to them
how did that enter the picture I
remember pretty vividly actually I was
living with my parents at the time and I
guess this was in 2011 when the 4-hour
body came out right yeah yeah 2000 2010
2011 4-hour body comes out okay so my
dad had cancer and he was trying to
research things that would you know make
him feel better
recover from that and I remember coming
down the stairs my parents house and I
hear my dad on the phone and he's like
yeah this guy he races motorcycles and
kick boxes and salsa our tango dances
and crazies like and it just kind of
perks my interest I'm like wait there's
one guy that like does all of these
things like I'm I'm like just playing
video games in my spare time this guy's
like living an amazing life this sounds
really interesting and so I wait for my
dad to get off the phone and I'm like
what are you talking about and he goes
oh I just found out about this book
called the 4-hour body it was mentioned
on a website called insta pundit yeah
and I've remember loading up Amazon and
then clicking on your name and then
seeing the 4-hour workweek and I'm like
hey now that sounds interesting and so I
remember getting a copy of the book and
I remember seeing page 90 like I was on
page and I Indy I'm like wow this is
like unlike any other book I've read
before this is blowing my mind
so that's how I stumbled into the world
I guess yeah it's it's kind of surreal
for me because I feel despite the fact
that I am now bald and once wasn't ten
years ago I feel like in some respects
it was just yesterday that I put that
book out so it's it's always wild
to come to the realization sometimes
it's been more than a decade now see you
see you you are reading this book you're
on page 90 and you've decided you want
to start your own business what what are
some of the first steps that you end up
taking well whether that's research or
actually giving it a go and building
something what were some of the very
first initial steps that you took well I
already had or how did you prepare for
it
I mean sure either/or so I actually have
my notes I don't know that you want me
to get up and grab them right now but I
actually have the original notes that I
took of each chapter and then the fear
setting exercises and everything okay
you know what let's yeah let's let's
grab it well you grab that I have to say
that I noticed that in interviewing
owners of million-dollar one-person
businesses that is a habit a number of
them have saved their original notes
from the 4-hour workweek and still refer
back to them today that's so wild yeah
cool so we have we have a yellow legal
pad
I used to use these as well because my I
grew up with my dad using legal yellow
notepads yeah I'm not sure what it is
about the notepads but yeah every book I
read I take notes like this and so for
our work week I wrote down some of the
quotes that you'd open each chapter with
and then other things that speak out to
me and so talking about deal deal for
those people have read the book is a
framework which is define eliminate
automate and liberate which correspond
to different activities and a process
that you can go through for among other
things building building businesses to
the generate cash flow and the fear
setting exercise that you did what do
you recall any of that oh yeah it looks
like I just basically wrote this entire
book a legal pad
so yeah define your nightmare what's the
absolute worst that could happen if you
did what you're considering and
I guess I was considering you know
leaving my job which was paying well and
then taking substantially less income
but being my own boss and so I wrote
down what the possible outcomes were
which were I lose at most $10,000 and
the time it took to make the company and
that's only if I fail right have some
other particularly far-fetched scenarios
anything you can share yeah I was
worried that my employer was gonna sue
me and then I was gonna have to spend a
lot of money in court and probably lose
a lot of more money if I lost or
something like that I don't know why I
thought I would get sued but you know
it's just yeah I mean part of the point
of the exercise is to put down these
oftentimes nonspecific or in some cases
ultimately unjustified fears because we
all have them but if you don't put them
on paper they're very hard to see for
what they are very hard to examine
anything else on the the worst case sure
so I said neither scenario is permanent
and I could definitely recover from
either of them the pain would be a three
to a four on a scale of one to ten if
either of these happened I don't think
the odds of them are very strong
if I were sued I would presumably have
enough money for a good lawyer to win
the suit so I mean this is just you know
absolute worst case scenario and even
then it really didn't even seem that bad
mm-hmm so you see you go through the
fear setting exercise which is called
fear setting for those people who are
wondering because it is somewhat akin to
goal setting in the sense that in either
case I should say in the case of goals
if they're not specific they're very
hard to achieve and then the case of
fear is if you're if you do not make
them really specific and define them
they're very hard to overcome or it can
be hard to overcome so it for those
people interested you can go to Tim not
blog forward slash Ted as in te D since
I gave a TED talk on this and and
provide all the forms and so on for you
to do this if you'd like to try it out
yourself so you do this exercise you
figure out that the the worst case
scenario is the downside risk is a
transient three to four from one to ten
and the potential upside is a lot higher
so what do you do then as some of your
any of your first steps that come to
mind you do this you're building up the
confidence notice I'm not saying courage
because courage kind of implies that
you're jumping into headlong into
complete unknown for a lot of people
whereas confidence is based on actually
doing some degree of analysis and
determining that you can you can
mitigate and tolerate the potential
downside risk and then sort of optimize
for forgetting it right so what did you
would do then do well I guess the next
thing I did was just quit my job yeah I
really wasn't even thinking about it
most people say to have a back-up plan
yeah excuse me um like just something to
fall back on and then start your
business on the side I decided to just
jump right into it I was so sick and
tired of working that job that I was at
that I gave my two weeks notice
and then after two weeks were up I was
like wow okay my and I'm not getting
checks anymore I need to like actually
get to work and so I think that I would
I think that I had actually gone to some
of the resources that are mentioned like
I specifically remember seeing Shopify
on there which is what I started my
store on and I'm still on that to this
day it's an e-commerce platform that
makes it really easy for you to oh this
is not a pitch basically Shopify just
allows me to have a website where it can
sell my stuff yeah they do they do a
really good job yeah and they're also
some of the nicest guys you would ever
made a bunch of a bunch of boys from
Ottawa Canada and it's now I guess the
most dominant ecommerce platform in the
US so you saw Shopify you're no longer
getting these checks yeah let me back up
for one second to ask you how did you
feel like you give your notice did you
do it in person via email via phone how
did you give your two-week notice
by email and that was only because my
boss he lived a distance away so I was
kind of working remotely for him oh yeah
no judgment at all I'm just wondering
how did it feel when you hit Send on
that and the email was sent it was a
huge relief and it was really funny
because about two minutes after I hit
Send one of the guys that I work with
yeah he got a phone call yeah from my
boss and then asked if he wanted to run
the company and then my boss didn't
actually respond to me for a week but I
was right next to the guy so I know he
read the email with the ten minutes
you had your your mole in the
organization all the Intel you needed
how appropriate okay see you see you see
you find some of these resources like
Shopify then what right because
ostensibly there are other people online
trying to sell right things like
surveillance equipment so how do you
think about increasing the likelihood of
success what are some of the what are
some of the other things that you did
well by this time I was really familiar
with Google Adwords and Google product
listings had just come out which made it
really it's known as Google Shopping now
but it made it really easy for you to
get in front of people like instantly so
I knew that if I were gonna start a
website then people don't just magically
show up they they kind of make it seem
like that's going to happen if you build
it they will come type of scenario and
that's not true at all it actually takes
a lot of work to build up traffic and so
with Google Ads I could pay to have
people who were highly targeted like
they were actually searching for like a
GPS tracker in Google and then my
website would come up and I'd have to
pay if they click on that link but I
just I purchased several books and I
read a lot of blog posts on Google
Adwords and so that's how I generated
traffic to the website initially and
it's still part of you know our traffic
strategy this day what are some of the
are there any particular resources if
you were sitting down with someone in a
non-competitive category let's just say
they have similar
parents they worked and I'll come back
to this I think it's a really important
point so they work somewhere where they
get an education on a certain product
category on someone else's dime yeah
other people's money really helpful and
that can be engineered and planned for
someone is doing that for who knows Lady
gaga like platform shoes right like
that's their specialty and if people are
like that's crazy you could never make a
business out of that go read one
thousand true fans by Kevin Kelley and
then come back to this podcast and you
will probably think differently but
let's just say that is their area of
expertise they worked in a shop they
know everything there is to know about
these sort of performer rock star type
platform shoes and they're looking to
approach it maybe in a similar way to
how you've approached your category are
there any resources books that you would
recommend for getting more familiar well
overall any that you would recommend and
then specifically to customer
acquisition maybe a paid marketing
pay-per-click whatever whatever comes to
mind are there any others that you found
or what found helpful or would recommend
sure so for our work week it's what got
the ball rolling and then there were a
couple of other books that I found super
helpful that I read around the same time
so choose yourself by James Altucher I
found really super helpful um it was
really fascinating to hear some of the
case studies that were in there because
it that book came out I don't know I
want to say maybe like five or six years
after 4-hour workweek did and and choose
yourself he also gives a lot of case
studies and I remember one of them being
I think the guy's name is Brian from
pate Braintree yeah yeah yeah Johnson
Brian Johnson is from Braintree who's
also been on the podcast yeah he did
alright for a few hundred million
dollars to eBay I think it is right but
he had really humble beginnings as well
you just started as like a really super
small credit card process I was selling
credit card processing
door-to-door I mean walking into
retailers so I found that to be
incredibly helpful and mostly just
reaffirming what for work like building
on what for work we had laid the
foundation for just kind of believing
that I had this in me to you know carve
a path mm-hmm
so that was one of them the other one
was a book called The Millionaire
Fastlane by MJ DeMarco and it's really
funny because all of the best books have
like the worst name yeah the 4-hour
workweek blessing in the curse yeah I
will teach you to be rich as another
resource that I've used a lot ramita
nineties he has courses that I've found
really helpful specifically the one on
copywriting mm-hmm
learned how to write significantly
better through that course the 22
immutable laws of marketing was
fantastic for just learning about what
you know sets brands apart and how to
position yourself and why it's important
to like try and create a category and
how there's different strategies that
you can employ he also wrote 22
immutable laws of branding which I
thought was really good as well but
doesn't get as much attention for some
reason yeah there's there's branding
marketing and then positioning I think
is another co-authored book all the
worth digesting some of the examples
they use are outdated much like a lot of
business books because no one can
predict the future so you look at good
to great well a lot of those so-called
great companies long since gone but
there are regime changes there are
macroeconomic changes and so on
nonetheless
when you read say the 22 immutable laws
of marketing the law of category the one
that you mentioned is particularly
important even if some of the examples
are a bit outdated these are all great
very complimentary examples were meat is
very very good at copywriting it's going
to underscore that and set these se th
eye and unchoose yourself I want to
highlight I mean James is a friend but I
knew
his work before I became friends with
him choose yourself I think is
particularly important in the example
you brought up is very appropriate
because whether it's Brian's story or I
would imagine a lot of the people you've
interviewed it's not as though people
have figured everything out and they
have a flawless plan that will be able
to execute reliably and then they start
their business there is a lot of testing
and having the confidence that you will
be able to figure it out which I think
you know Brian is a good example of as
well so you have these resources you've
done a bunch of homework you have some
practice with Google Adwords
then what so I built up the website and
to that I needed to take product
photography I didn't have any unique
images at all so one of things I'd
recommend is if you're using
manufacturer images that's a terrible
terrible thing to do you really need to
be taking your own product images you
can do it much better and it's good for
SEO and other things like that so I
bought a little what do they call it a
white box we don't like the product in
and then I took photos of it and then I
remember I did all of this from a
two-bedroom apartment in Richardson
Texas it's a suburb of Dallas and I just
remember staying up really late my wife
would come in and like you know I kiss
her goodnight and then I'd put on
Spotify I'd have music that I'd listen
to like the same stuff over and over
again like I wanted your playlist yeah
the playlist it was just the same like
album what did you listen to
I listened well two albums the first one
was an album called the master plan by
Oasis and then what was the other one it
was
welcome to interstate managers by
Fountains of Wayne I don't know why but
I would just have those on repeat and it
was good for working and so I would be
writing product descriptions and
I remember I bought like a dollar you
know Kindle book and learn how to write
product descriptions and it was
difficult but eventually you bought a
Kindle book on how to write product
descriptions yes
specifically how to write seductive web
copy was what it was called yeah so I
would write product descriptions I would
be editing the photos so taking photos
uploading them making sure everything
looked good I did this all with a it was
a hundred and forty dollar theme on
Shopify and which is amazing because I
remember at a previous company that I
worked for we spent like thirty thousand
dollars on a website hit it like was so
difficult to like edit and make the way
you wanted and for a hundred and forty
bucks you could get a theme that was
like really really good like it was
already optimized for conversions and
easy to edit and so I just remember
being so stoked that I was able to get
this thing up and running for you know
only a few hundred dollars and so
writing web copy taking photos you know
trying to optimize my Google ad
campaigns before they went live because
I didn't want to like turn on the
campaign and then go to bed and then all
sudden I spent like seven thousand
dollars like overnight
yeah that's not it's not a happy morning
yeah it was just getting the website to
be good enough that I could turn the ad
campaign on and then people would come
to my website and make a purchase and as
long as I was breaking even at in the
beginning I was I would have been happy
so I could cover the cost of the product
that I was selling cover the cost of the
ads that I was paying for and yeah I
turned my ad campaign on in I had
started working on the business in March
for some reason it took me like an
additional two months to make it go live
I think it took more time than I
realized
to get going and I remember thinking oh
my gosh I'm gonna have to like find a
job or something before this website
launches I was probably just being a
little too perfectionist I've not only
just need to push it live
and so I remember it was May 23rd
I turned the campaign on at like 3:00
a.m. I'm like all right it's time to
make this thing happen then I go to bed
and then I wake up at like 7:00 a.m. and
I roll over and look at my phone and I
have a notification from Shopify saying
that I made my first sale for 149
dollars and I let out this huge like
orgasmic noise Wow like everything's
gonna be okay yeah so it was like a huge
just validation that you know I had it
in me to do the entrepreneur thing I
guess yeah that first sale I mean I I
remember some of my very first sales
with anything that you've started from
scratch and because there's at least in
my case and I think a lot of cases
there's this there's this [ __ ] little
little doubt in the back that's like I'm
not sure if this is actually gonna work
or if it can work and then when you have
that first sale you're like okay this
actually might work I want to do that
and feel free to jump in at any time I
know I'm kind of on a roll here because
I've had plenty of caffeine as well but
the the the wife so how did you present
to her before you quit if you did I
don't know not everyone does the
prospect of starting your own gig was
that an easy conversation was that a
hard conversation how did you approach
that I don't think it was a particularly
difficult conversation she had a job at
the time and it was you know it's like
okay money it wasn't amazing or anything
like that but we had money saved up from
my job and then her income so I figured
you know we'd be able to get by if this
didn't pan out and she knew I was really
unhappy and I don't know she was cool
with it
I had to explain it to her parents
though who were much more skeptical
I remember sitting down in their living
room and I was like I casually mentioned
that I was like quitting my job or
whatever to start a business and you
know pretty much everyone when you say
that like they instantly like kind of I
don't wanna say they judge you but a lot
of them are like are you sure you really
want to do that because you know it's a
stable income and they maybe they think
you'll fail or something like that but I
felt like I had a lot of people that
weren't entirely sure with my decision
and so I remember explaining to them
like yeah so this is how Google Ads
works and like I lost them as soon as I
mentioned that they're like this Google
you talk of how long have you been
married at that time oh I think like a
year only here yeah yep just about a
year what are the benefits that I kind
of ashamed I've never talked about
before one of the benefits of an
exercise like the fear setting exercise
is that you can then use that you've
done the thinking through of many of the
things that will jump immediately to
mind for someone who is maybe blindsided
or hasn't done all the thinking on the
leap like you have and then you have
ready answers because you've already
gone through the outright all of the
worst case scenarios that you've been
able to come up with so you have your
first sale what was it 149 dollars you
said yeah one 49.99 one $49.99 what was
the item what did you sell it was a
voice recorder it's just a really small
it's not even so we still concealed
recorders like an hidden inside of a pen
for example but this one is just a
really small recorder with a long
battery life and for whatever reason
customers really like it and that was
the first time I sold and soon L walk
walk us through the the next steps what
happens then because I'm sure there are
people listening and I'm wondering as
well do you have a bedroom slash garage
full of of inventory you're hoping to
sell do you have people in China
do you have what say
you you see so the order is placed then
what happens at that point and maybe
it's changed but at that point what what
happens yeah I think as of the first day
that we went live we were probably
getting like ten orders a day and yeah
this is in my second bedroom and I don't
I have ten thousand dollars worth of
inventory in this bedroom and is that
ten thousand dollars you have spent on
the inventory or ten thousand dollars
okay guys so the retail value would be
dire yeah and so I was like too cheap to
buy shelving for it too so it's just
scattered everywhere like all over the
floor and up against the walls and stuff
my wife hated it and yeah so I also had
like packing supplies yes you know you
got to get customers or stuff right and
so I'd have boxes and packing paper and
envelopes and everything like that you
were smarter than I was I did packing
peanuts back in the day and my worst
disaster yeah whenever I see people
whenever people shoot me in peanuts I'm
like you open the box
haribol customer experience yeah people
were placing orders I remember we were
probably spending about a hundred to two
hundred dollars on AdWords each day and
getting no organic traffic at all and so
in the $200 was that eight was that
eight that was a limit that you would
set yourself or had yeah that was a
limit that it said just to make sure I
didn't suddenly you know spend a couple
thousand dollars because I made some
really tiny mistake like I had a dash
somewhere yeah it shouldn't be there
right so we were spending
yeah about one to two hundred dollars a
day I had a cap on it so we wouldn't go
over that until I could look at the
numbers and then make sure that you know
we were actually profitable and it kind
of took off from there we started
spending a little bit more money we
started getting more data from Google
like how people were finding us like
exactly the keywords that they were
typing in doing some a be testing with
the ad itself so we would change the
copy of the ad or like the headline of
the ad to see which perform better and
yeah things really took off once I
started yeah I mean what we could do we
could come back to some of the smartest
earlier decisions that you made like in
retrospect like okay these were really
important decisions okay I want to talk
about the bedroom in the inventory yes
so the $10,000 of inventory
suppose you want me to riff on that for
like a second I'd love for you to riff
on that because there there are many
different ways to try to approach this
inventory question sure right so how did
you make the decision to fill up the
bedroom two parts right so the first is
like how did you make that decision and
then if you were to do it over again
would you do it the same or differently
all right so when we went live I had
about 10,000 in inventory scattered
across the bedroom and I was fulfilling
all the orders myself so around 3 p.m.
each day I would you know stand up start
looking for whatever it was that
customers had ordered and then pack it
and then I'd have to throw it into the
back of my car and drive to the post
office and I did that every day for
about six months or so and then it
became a huge issue because my car
couldn't holds enough like the trunk
wasn't big enough to hold all the
packages and then I was also living on a
third floor apartment and I'd have to
drive at the post office and then when I
was purchasing inventory from overseas
they'd ship it to a private mailbox that
I had it was like a you know it's not a
UPS Store it's like a private mailbox
and they would accept the shipment for
me and then I have to go pick it up
these huge boxes I'd have to get them in
my wife's car because my car wasn't big
enough to carry all of it and then I
have to carry it up three flights of
stairs into the bedroom and then unpack
it
and there would be cardboard dust and
all sorts of crap everywhere it was like
a mass and then I have to go back
downstairs and throw away all the
cardboard and this is my life for like
six months by the time that let me think
by the end of the year I started the
business I had my first sale like in May
in a year oh this is in 2014 and so
November's rolling around and I'm like I
can't do this anymore
just packing orders is taking up like
two to three hours of my day and all
while I'm also answering phone calls
because I have my phone number
Brighton Center at the top of the
webpage as soon as people land on it
everyone can see the phone number
whereas most ecommerce stores actually
like try to hide it I wanted people to
call cuz I knew I could close them over
the phone and so they would call and IB
which you knew you could do because you
had a lot of experience also it reached
exactly yeah talking to customers that
that was so beneficial because I'd be on
the other side of a counter from the
customer and they'd come in and they'd
say I've got this problem like I think
somebody is abusing my parent in an
alzheimer home or I think something's
going on with my kid they're autistic I
think the other kids are like bullying
them what do you have for that and so I
would be able to gauge how they felt
about certain products and just pick
them with the perfect item so when they
called I already knew what most of their
problems were and it allowed me to just
definitively say like this is the thing
that's going to solve your issue and so
yeah I had no idea yes you you were
doing hours of picking and packing every
day I was doing like you're doing all of
live chat and phone calls live chat
phone call and then picking and packing
orders all at the same time and I
remember I mean one of my favorite
stories to tell was going out to lunch I
went to in and out and I was doing three
live chats all at the same time and then
I had a customer place like a $2,000
order
like while they were in a live chat with
me and I'm like sitting it in and out
eating a burger like man this is crazy
like I never would have thought that
something like this were possible and so
I was doing all of those things at the
same time and it I was neglecting the
AdWords campaign entirely because that
was just very data-driven and I didn't
have the I guess the bandwidth to go in
and analyze all of this stuff and so I
kind of let that go on autopilot for a
couple of months and then that doesn't
really work very well and yeah so I
decided to hire an employee and I guess
that was about six or seven months after
I started that I'm starting yeah just to
help with customer service so let's talk
we're gonna come back to the employee
but the I don't let the inventory go
just yet okay because people listening
are like 10 grand oh my god that's so
much money did you decide to do that
because you had you knew which items or
you had a high degree of confidence in
which items would sell and you just felt
most comfortable buying the inventory it
was because you didn't know of other
ways to approach it besides buying
inventory could could you explain having
the confidence to spend 10,000 bucks and
maybe it was credit card financed
instead of out of your bank account I
have no idea but yeah I think account it
was yes and so there are a couple
reasons why I had the inventory there
number one was it was coming from
overseas and I didn't know how the whole
a packet thing really worked I don't
even know what that is oh really
what's that so that's when you order
stuff it's really popular with Chinese
factories they'll actually just start
listing products that they sell on
Amazon and then they use it's subsidized
by the United States to send extremely
cheap packages very quickly so it
actually costs like only a couple
dollars to send something from like you
know Beijing or Shanghai or Shenzhen
they'll send it over to the US for just
like two or three dollars Wow like that
to the end
the recipient yes and that's really
popular with FBA sellers right now FBA
stands for fulfillment by Amazon so
that's a really hot business model at
the moment where a lot of companies they
list products that are currently being
made in China they'll list those on
Amazon and then when the item sells
they'll just pick up the art they'll
just email to factory and say hey I need
you to send this package over to my
customer in California or whatever and
they'll get it within like a few days
and it only costs a couple dollars
whereas for somebody to actually have
inventory in Texas and then ship it to
California it actually cost more than
that so at the time that you got the
inventory you were not familiar with
maybe it didn't even exist I don't know
how long this has been in existence but
e packet so you did not want to have to
wait a long period of time it would take
in like two weeks or something like that
for the customer to get it also the fact
so some of the factories just
straight-up won and even do that for me
they weren't willing to do you can kind
of think of it as like a drop shipping
model yeah where once the item is sold
then you actually you know purchase it
from the manufacturer
whoever's distributing it and then
they'll ship it on your behalf and so
some of my suppliers didn't want to do
that and so I would actually have to put
in an order for like 100 or 200 units or
something like that in order to actually
have that inventory to sell by the
customer right how did you choose which
products you would buy for that initial
ten thousand dollars of inventory I knew
that most of my sales were going to come
from just a handful of products so it's
like the whole 80/20 thing knows based
on your previous just based on the
previous experience I want to pause for
just one second to really highlight this
because very often I meet folks who want
to say start their business their first
business right out of college and
sometimes that is a great approach
sometimes it works out really well but
whenever possible I like to recommend
that people do their real-world MBA by
learning on someone else's dime and
acquiring some of the skills and testing
some of the things that you tested
before then gambling with limited
savings that you might have
so anyway speech complete speech speech
complete I think I remember you telling
me Alan that you also picked the
inventory with an eye on which ones
would not be returned a lot based on
what you had learned in the Stewart do
you remember that yeah
and that's something we still do so a
lot of my competitors though a lot of
people just want to sell anything and
everything they possibly can but I sell
electronics and electronics are really
difficult to it's a difficult industry
and because you have to give like tech
support to customers whereas with other
things like soft goods like you know
bags and clothing and stuff like that
those do have high return rates but you
don't really have to talk to the
customer at all whereas with tech
support that's like a huge customer
service thing and so I only when I
started and I still do we only carry
stuff that we really really like and
that's high quality so that when our
customers get it they're not like really
irritated that's like you know a piece
of crap electronic that's like barely
working that was imported from China or
something like that if you were to go to
Amazon and type in like you know spy
camera or something
most of the stuff that's listed is like
only two-and-a-half stars three stars
it's being sent directly by the factory
in China and they don't offer tech
support at all and so we try to just
carry products that we know our
customers are gonna love that they're
not gonna want to return that are easy
to provide tech support on and that's
worked out really well for us so the
what I'm hearing and please correct me
if I'm wrong but it's it's it gives me
an opportunity also clarify my position
on something which is I am not against
high touch customer service so some some
people who have read said for our work
we both will think that everything
should be automated but there are there
there are certain instances where for
instance you are able to use not just
product or SEO or something else as a
competitive advantage but use customer
support as a competitive advantage which
can be a huge competitive
Motz so to speak like it put it
insulates and protects your business in
a lot of ways because it it is it is a
hurdle that many other people are not
going to be willing to make right you're
not going to have it's very unlikely
you're gonna have some competitor in
like Armenia who's going to decide to
offer high-touch support in English it's
just it's or anywhere else
it's it's it's a there's a steeper
learning curve and you have experience
that gives you an advantage in
implementing that so I'm glad that we're
talking about this because it ultimately
I mean you started in 2014 you said
right we're now in as we're recording
this soon-to-be 2019 and you're still
going strong as far as I can tell yes
and that is not the case with a lot of
folks who anticipate that there one
connection to one manufacturer and their
batch of 30 secret keywords is going to
keep them alive forever which is very
very rarely the case right so coming
back to where we left off before I drag
us back into the world of inventory
which i think is important the employee
now did you decide to make them a
full-time hire right off the bat did you
how did you find them and walk us
through the thought process for was
there a breaking point also was there
like a specific day where you were just
like enough I need to get this fixed
and walk us through the thought process
I don't know that there was a specific
day I just remember the general feeling
of dread I had whenever like 2 or 3 p.m.
would roll by and I'm like oh my gosh
the phone hasn't stopped ringing I have
to pack all of these orders I got to go
to the post office which was just such a
drag going up and down the stairs of my
apartment and then also just I had to
wait in line at the post office just to
give them a bag full of like a trash bag
full of stuff they want to let me drop
it off
so I might be there for like 15 to 20
minutes until they'll accept the
packages and yeah I'd realized that it
was taking up too much of my time and I
was still like kind of referring back to
the 4-hour workweek like every couple
months I'd kind of like go back and be
like okay well
doing right here and I realized that I
wasn't kind of offloading the $10 an
hour tasks so that I could focus on the
you know one hundred or a thousand
dollar an hour town si in and out phone
golf tasks yes two thousand dollar order
tasks yeah exactly
and so I'm like you know I really want
to quit it with this post office thing I
don't really know what to do the the 3pl
the third party fulfillment fees if I
were to have somebody else take this
over from me would just be far too high
third play fulfillment meaning you find
a center which will house your inventory
right and interface with you in some way
for order processing and and so on yeah
they just got the costs and all that
yeah exactly and so you know there's a
pallet somewhere with my products on it
and they'll pack it for me and ship it
out and it's usually like a flat rate
but it was gonna really eat into the
margins and so I was just like you know
I can't be on the phone all day anymore
I really need help but phone I mean
phone orders make up like twenty percent
of our sales so I can't just turn off
the phone really so I decided to I
decided to go back to one of the guys
that actually trained me in the
surveillance industry and from that
original student from the original yeah
in 2009 it was May 2009 I got hired at
that store and they had four locations
at the time in each location had its own
sales manager and so my first week of
the job each day was at a different
store in North Texas and on Friday I
remember it being on a Friday I went
into the location that he still works
with me his name's Vince and I remember
going into Vince's store and he was
teaching me about setting up the CCTV
like DVR so that would like record on
motion and then he had like a you know a
8 camera package system that he was
closing the sale on and so he was
packing up all the cameras and the
cables and the power supplies and then
he showed me like how the GPS trackers
were
and just all of it and then all of the
crazy stories that you might expect to
hear you know from a brick-and-mortar
spy shop I just remember being so much
fun
and so he is you know my favorite guy to
work with at the store and I didn't know
who else to turn to because this is kind
of a weird industry and it takes a lot
of like customer knowledge and I just
didn't have it in me to teach anybody
else like what I knew so I went to him
and it was an opportune time for him and
so we decided to make that happen like
in I think it was like the February or
March of 2015
mm-hmm yeah and what was what was the
first week like with him it was great I
mean he worked from home you know so we
don't live in the same city at all but
through the wonders of the internet you
know I was able to make it so that if
somebody were to call 800 number on the
website then it would ring him on his
computer and that's all he did at the
time was just customer service customer
support okay so you were still handling
the the picking ask us still doing the
picking and packing but at least I
wasn't taking as many phone calls and so
we grew to the point where we were
getting more phone calls and then I have
to get on the phone again it was just
impossible for me to do things from the
third floor of my apartment and so Vince
has a house with a garage and I'm like
hey he can take care of all the shipping
and all of the phone support and do live
chats and stuff for me so I just like
really offloaded stuff to him which was
great because when he wasn't on a call
then he could be placing the orders
throughout the day he didn't just have
to wait until like 2:00 or 3:00 p.m.
like I was because the inventory was
just hanging out in his garage and so he
became my fulfillment guy in addition to
the customer service and so I finally
got all the inventory stuff out of my
hair were you a good manager from the
outset did you have experience from
working in previous jobs or was that
something you had to learn how to do no
I definitely had to learn how to do it I
had to learn that on my next employee
because the first one was the guy that
trained me
and so he was pretty much autonomous
like he could just do his thing and I
didn't really even have to think about
it at all
but then when I had my second employee
that's what I like
oh so this is why everyone complains
about managing employees and having
teams and you know just I know so many
entrepreneurs that say that running that
managing the team is like the hardest
part of their job and finding employees
and I totally get that now
that was the lesson that most people
aren't on the first employee for me that
was my second you're like I don't know
what everyone's complaining I see you
get this the second employee how much
later did you hire them did you bring
them on immediately full-time as a
contractor and then what what helped you
to learn how to manage them yeah I think
that was a full year after I heard the
first one it was a friend of mine that
was probably the first place that went
wrong is it a good friend of mine who
was also unhappy with his job and I
don't know I think it's because I I
really wanted to help him out and I
needed somebody to help out with my
company too I was still spending a lot
on paid advertising and I'm like me and
I haven't had any time to focus on SEO
related tasks and projects search engine
optimization for organic yes getting
people to come to the site without
having to pay for each visit exactly
mm-hmm so I knew that was a priority and
my friend had no marketing experience
whatsoever but he's a really nice guy
and he hated his job and I needed
somebody to commiserate with like on the
whole entrepreneurship front and I'm
like you know maybe he can just like
kind of be an apprentice type of person
I'll teach him what I know and then
he'll go on and do something else and
all the while like he's helping me you
know build a company and then that's
when I realized that I had no idea what
I was doing with managing people like
this guy knew nothing about my industry
he didn't know anything about marketing
and I'm like wait I have to teach him
all this stuff like or get him courses
and books and things like that this is
like gonna be a huge drag and so he
worked for me for like a couple of
but it he ended up going back into his
industry which is HR just because it
paid significantly better than I did and
yeah I don't know so in looking back at
that what should you have done instead
if you were giving advice to your
younger self and I understand like we
all learn valuable things from all
experiences and so on but what what what
should you have done instead or what
advice would you have gift what would
what advice would you give to someone in
that same situation or they're like I
need somebody else but I don't know what
to do yeah I wouldn't have hired a
friend and I know a lot of other
business owners that feel the same way
it's not for everybody
I mean I'm sure some people can make it
work but it was very difficult for me
because I ended up having to just have
like uncomfortable conversations and
stuff in it like kind of hurt the
friendship a little bit so I did that
wrong and then if I were going to go
back and do it again I would have there
a couple of options that are available
now that weren't really available a
couple years ago that I've that have
worked out really well for me so yeah
like what there are a lot of job boards
out there now for people who are looking
for a remote work like a lot of job
boards and they're there any age are
there any that you yeah I have a
favorite one what is called dynamite
jobs and the web sites dynamite jobs dot
CEO there's no M the guy that one of the
calm one and too much money
probably yeah so full disclaimer this is
run by some friends of mine but it's for
people who are looking for
apprenticeships or jobs where they're
giving like a meaningful role they're
not just clocking in and doing the you
know nine-to-five type of thing this is
for people who they want to work
remotely they want to learn things and
they're able to a lot of them choose to
live like in Southeast Asia because the
cost of living is so low that they're
high quality they're affordable and they
also want to work for come
means that are doing interesting things
and so I've gone through and I've looked
at a lot of jobs that are on there and
I'm like hey this would've been like
amazing for me like before I started
this entrepreneurship thing I totally
would have done that there's another one
called ro motive dot IO and then we work
remotely is another one I have heard
about that one yeah there's all sorts of
like when niche ones so like if you're a
programmer or if you're just a customer
service person or if you want to work in
like content marketing that type of
thing then they're there you know a lot
of niche job boards for opportunities
like that were there any resources books
or otherwise that eventually helped you
to learn to be more effective as a
manager yeah the one that comes to mind
instant like the instant you said that
was one that I only read like a couple
months ago I wish I picked it up sooner
cuz it's really short it's called the
one minute manager mm-hmm they have a
new one it's called the new one minute
manager knew about it it's kind of
updated for organizations that are not
as they don't have as much hierarchy
it's more for like you know 20 18
businesses where they're like more flat
mmhmm yeah
this this book has come up a fair amount
and it's what's nice about it is that
it's very short I mean it is very very
very digestible as opposed to some of
these other books on management that are
like university textbooks and I think it
people just drown in the information you
mentioned hiring a friend as being
probably a mistake or something that
that in your particular circumstances
would have been a mistake what are any
other mistakes that come to mind that
you made in the first year or two we're
like you know what are advising someone
I would probably do that differently I
didn't outsource the whole paid traffic
thing soon enough like that that's a
very brain intensive task like dumping a
bunch of data into Excel and analyzing
it and finding out what keywords were
performing and which ones weren't I let
that go on autopilot for far too long
and it probably cost me a lot of money
like
six or seven months after I started my
business but I was so inundated with all
these you know menial tasks that I
didn't go back to the thing that was
actually like making me money which was
like all of the paid traffic that was
coming in and so I would have outsourced
at like significantly sooner to somebody
who really really knew what they were
doing how would you have found that
person or that company probably through
referrals most the stuff that I do now
and companies that I hire I usually hear
about from other business owners how do
you meet those business owners you go to
a lot of events what types of it what
types of events so it's not just event
this isn't kind I'm asking because this
is a very common question where I hear
from people who say I would love to do X
but I can't find like-minded people
which I think may be a cop-out because
they're certainly out there it's really
easy to say that when you're first
starting out but there are people out
there like a lot of people out there
that are doing interesting things that
you want to be a part of and they're
willing to like let you in in that world
and so let's talk about going to events
first yeah so there are conferences that
you can go to for pretty much any
industry that you're interested in
I go to ecommerce related conferences
where there's people who are selling
stuff online that's the thing that we
have in common I don't go to any
industry events for like spy gear or
surveillance stuff I used to but I don't
really like it the e-commerce events are
really helpful because most people there
are willing to share what they know and
they they're excited about it and
they're not concerned about people you
know stealing their idea quotes -
they're not worried about that sort of
thing
they're in their business they are
already running big teams they're
looking to grow even further and
e-commerce is changing like pretty
constantly like there's always like new
things to try and you know everybody's
always concerned about what Amazon is
doing and like how to counteract
and so you go to these conferences where
just other like-minded people are going
to be in you strike up conversations and
I have tips for conferences if you want
to get some point
dick you mentioned one or two
conferences you've enjoyed for
e-commerce and then tips for conferences
sure because this is people might be
thinking well hold on a second I just
want to set up a business does this
doesn't seem relevant it's really
relevant or it's way to fast-track a lot
of your learning and this is this is
also something that I've done at various
points in my career whenever I've wanted
to take a new path is to spend time at
the at conferences so yeah if could you
MIT could you mention a few conferences
that you've enjoyed and then what your
PlayBook is sure when I first started in
2014 the conference that really kicked
things off for me was Internet Retailer
it's an annual event in Chicago it's a
big one yeah it's huge
I actually don't go to it anymore
because it kind of feels like a
corporate getaway
like there's huge companies there like
walmart.com and it's just BH photo/video
these huge companies that I have nothing
that I can relate to and a lot of the
sessions are more for like you know
enterprise type of clients but they do
have beginner related stuff you do get
to go to the exhibit hall where they
have all sorts of software vendors who
are providing services that you can use
to run your e-commerce website or your
customer service or your logistical
needs like shipping and you strike up
conversations and the exhibitor booths
and you get introduced to people it's
really cool so that was really helpful
when I first started the the one that I
went to and I was like I can never miss
this event ever again is a conference
called well it's a private community of
location independent store owners so
people who are Tim Ferriss wannabes
basically
so it's it's called I mentioned the job
board earlier it's called dynamite
circle and they have an annual event in
Bangkok each year in each October and
it's really cool they get about 300
entrepreneurs and we rent out the Conrad
hotel in Bangkok and it's like summer
camp for people who are doing business
online and working from their computers
and managing remote teams and it's just
like a five or six day event and it's
really cool you meet so many people just
hanging out in the lobby like that's my
number one tip for anybody who goes to a
conference is actually stay at the
conference hotel it's gonna cost more
money but there's all sorts of like
serendipitous events that happen when
you're just like hanging out in the
lobby and or sitting at the bar and you
start talking to somebody and all sudden
you realize that you have a lot in
common or there's something that you
guys can work on together and business
deals happen it's really cool any other
any other tips for for conferences it's
really tempting to stay out and drink at
night and stay out until like 2:00 a.m.
but then by the time you get back to
your hotel at 3:00 a.m. you don't want
to go to the session that's starting at
like 8:00 or 9:00 a.m. so I would
probably just advise that you should
probably call it a night at like
midnight and then actually attend the
conference later in the morning that's a
lesson I am always learning there's a
conference here we're sitting in Austin
Texas called South by Southwest every
year which is where for our work we
actually had one of its very first
tipping points in 2007 and I've come
back pretty much every year since and
for those people are interested in in
why I value conferences for certain
things in how I approach it you could
just look for how to build a world-class
network and my name I actually think I
did I put out audio on the podcast about
how I approached it but one quick tip
would be I'll give two quick tips the
first is that pay attention if there are
panels pay attention to the moderators
because very often after
a session all the panelists will get
rushed and the moderator will just be
left there cold by themselves that is an
e that represents an easier person to
talk to and by the way if they're
moderating the panel they know all of
the panelists so be nice be curious and
connect with moderators not just
panelists the second is if you are going
to be one of those hundred people
rushing the stage to try to get a word
in edgewise with person X don't try to
get a word in edgewise well maybe just a
few words which is I wrote you this note
I know you're super slammed right now
but if you could read it think you might
find interesting that's it do your
thinking and you're pitching on paper
and give it to them for later because
nobody does that even though even though
I've recommended this still probably one
out of a hundred people will do it next
to no one does it and more often than
not they will stick it in their pocket
and then when they're having coffee or a
meal later they'll be like what the hell
is this is my pocket oh it's a note let
me read it so those would be two
recommendations I want to come back to
sort of the beginnings for a moment
since we talked about fear setting but
we didn't talk about dream lining or
lifestyle goals what were some of the
goals that you had for your life end or
the business when you first got going
like what was what did success
potentially look like to you I tried
finding my dream lines I think I tore
him out of here at some point I know I
have them but I remember thinking that
if I could make $30,000 a year that I'd
be okay
and my wife want to leave me and I could
pay my bills because dual income so
together we would have been fine by
myself
30,000 probably would have been all that
great but if I could make 30,000 a year
then all this will have been worthwhile
I'll have time to pursue stuff that
interested me like I was still really
interested in playing music and yeah I
just remember 30,000 being just the
number that I needed to hit and did you
and you arrived at that just by
crunching your expenses and figure
yeah I think that's pretty much a burn
rate yeah exactly and so I did the whole
targeted monthly income exercise I wrote
out what I my short-term goals I can't
remember the exact links but like what
do I want six weeks from now and then
like three yes six months twelve months
exactly yeah and so some of it was like
what am i what am i doing what am I
having like owning that sort of thing
yeah and so I can remember some of the
things on there were like I want eight
percent body fat percent body fat I want
to be able to have conversational
Spanish skills so I could talk to my
grandma in Spanish I wanted a really
cool leather jacket that I could like
pass down to like my kid one day because
I never had a really cool jacket and I
used to wear my dad's in high school
just stuff great great the for people
wondering also you don't have to get you
don't have to buy the 4-hour workweek to
to see this type of she if you just
search Tim Ferriss streamlining there
there are all of this stuff is available
for free on the blog as well so you set
out these things did you check off some
of those some of those items on the like
to be to have to do I'm certain I did I
don't remember all of them offhand but I
do remember doing the exercise like
pretty regularly yeah like I want to say
like once a year do you have leather
jacket yeah you certainly have the money
for it though so here's the deal I know
I didn't hit the 8% body fat yeah and I
was just going through this weird time
where I'm like wait I got it like really
bulk up first and then I gotta buy a
leather jacket otherwise I want to get
stuck with two leather jacket yeah I
don't know I kind of reasoned myself out
of the whole leather jacket thing but
maybe I should go grab one while I'm
down here this is a great town for 11
Vince actually you know Elaine you
suggested a couple of questions that I
think are really worth exploring do you
want to perhaps bring this one up
because I am
very curious to hear the answer sure
yeah I was wondering a lot of the
internet stores that I interview are on
Amazon you're not right
tell us about your thinking on that well
there are a couple ways that I've
approached this and the first reason was
because I was afraid of the really high
return rates getting me in trouble with
Amazon so it's my understanding and this
could be outdated but I'm pretty sure
that once you get over a 10 percent
return rate then Amazon just kind of
penalized as you like they can remove
the listing entirely and so I remember
from previous experience that a lot of
times my products were just like too
technical for some users or the bigger
one was that I was afraid that somebody
was gonna use my products for whatever
they needed like I need this catch 1
video right on an event basis exactly
and Amazon is like a 30 day return
policy or whatever and I was like oh my
gosh that's like enough time for
somebody to use this product get all of
the value they needed out of it and then
send it back and then I'm like totally
burned by it and so I was able to
mitigate that by having you know my own
store where I could set my own return
policy and not have to worry about it
Amazon also eats in the margins a little
bit and I also was worried about it was
mostly a fear-based thing yeah for sure
for not selling on Amazon I knew I could
make it work on my own and then Amazon
just seemed like a little bit of an
issue that I wasn't ready to take on at
least that's when I first started the
business now like many things I start
seeing things in different ways and so I
do see Amazon as like a sales channel
that I can be taking advantage of and so
I'm trying to figure out how best to
approach that like I'd really like to
start manufacturing my own products and
that way I'm not having to compete with
other people for the same exact item so
that's one of the other reasons I was
worried that you know I'd list the item
on Amazon and then all of a sudden you
have like
or seven other people attaching
themselves to the listing also saying
that they are selling this item which
I'm not entirely sure that they are it
could be like a counterfeit or a copycat
or something like that and then you're
all fighting for the buy box it just
seemed like something I didn't want on
my plate and I knew it can make it work
without it and he started doing any
manufacturing I think you had mentioned
you were exploring that yeah so
production line hasn't started yet but I
did find an industrial designer who
lives here in Austin and we've been
working on some products together and
I've also found an engineer that is
making the PCBs design for me so that's
printed circuit board and it's been a
hard road I mean there's a reason why
people don't if you're trying to get
into fulfilled by Amazon businesses the
the rule one is don't sell electronics
it's far and so I'm not technical it's
been a really hard road figuring out how
electronics worked what are the costs Oh
some of the stuff comes out defective
and I got to deal with that and then you
got to communicate with factories in
China because there that's like the hub
for everything electronics these days
and it's just been really difficult to
figure out I think I'm getting there but
we do have products designed I want to
sell them under the spy-guy brand and
then be in control of the actual product
that we're making it's been kind of a
pain being at the mercy of other of the
manufacturer because sometimes they
don't orders take too long or they jack
up your prices and it just kind of feels
like they have you over a barrel so I'm
looking to actually start manufacturing
my own items yes what what are some of
the tools that you've found helpful for
running your business or automating
certain things I mean you mentioned live
chat for instance which was starting way
back in the day yes way back in the day
meaning not not all that long ago I
guess in terms of humans on the planet
but in in entrepreneurship years a long
time what are what are some of the
technologies or tools that you currently
use that you find very helpful
sure so Shopify
is just the hub of everything that we do
and that's what it talks to everything
else pretty much it's fantastic it makes
life so much easier than when I was on I
used to work at a company and we were
using Yahoo Store you remember that oh
yeah oh my god it hasn't changed
it hasn't changed since you used it so
Shopify is the hub of everything that we
do it collects all of the data and we
base all of our decisions off of it we
have another tool that's really helpful
called
help Scout it is a ticket software so
that you're not just in Gmail all day it
makes it really easy to for customers to
contact you and for you to give them the
exact experience that your customer
needs so like if they email you asking
for a refund or a return then you have
like canned responses that you can key
in and you can assign tickets so like if
a customer's like hey I talked to Dale
the other day I'd really like it if he
could help me with this issue then you
can like move that ticket into his inbox
and then he can manage it and you can
see the entire history of the customers
profile like you can see everything that
they've done in Shopify also appears and
help Scout so you can see the orders
that they've placed you can see if
they've been refunded so you can do all
of your customer service stuff just with
an help scout and not having to like
open a new window and go to Shopify so
that's really good for streamlining
things one of my biggest wins was using
a shipping software called shipping easy
there's another one that's out there
called shipstation that is also popular
Thank You per station I might be getting
this wrong I feel like they might be
based here in Austin also they are yes
so shipping easy I really yeah in there
otherwise known by the same company yeah
they're always won like the Gucci and
then the other ones like the the the
more affordable I think that's kind of
it yeah well hey so the start is two
separate ones and then they were both
bought buy stamps calm
which also owns indicia I don't know
they have like a monopoly on the
post-office and I'm not sure how that
works that's really weird but the
shipping software is incredible because
an order will come through on our
Shopify website and then it gets synced
to shipping easy so that a label is
automatically generated so what we've
done is we have a set of automation
rules so shipping easy knows how much
each item weighs what envelope or box
the item will be shipped out in based on
like the total order weight and the
shipping method that the customer
selected so if they did free ground
shipping that's probably gonna go out
first-class mail but if they selected
two-day shipping then it's probably
going to go out like FedEx one rate or
you know we have a million different
combinations that are in there and it's
really easy to set up so that like
within a minute of a customer placing an
order on the website a shipping label is
generated and we know exactly what
envelope it's going to go into and what
products and is that then presumably the
orders get shipped out of a fulfillment
center at this point and not out of we
have enough goods now oh you have an
office yeah we have all of her in before
at the office I had tried doing the 3pl
thing it was a total disaster
I know other people who it works great
for them they're typically only have
like a handful of SKUs yeah and I think
that makes it easier we have like closer
to a hundred and we had a lot of issues
with the 3pl with wrong orders getting
sent out that was actually like one of
the most stressful periods ever because
I thought my business was going to
implode mmm customers getting wrong
orders wanting to cancel them
filing charge backs all the time it was
very frustrating so we have an office
now and I have a full time fulfillment
guy who comes in in the morning and he's
really the only employee I have that has
to go to an office and he'll pack the
orders and then we don't have to drive
at the post office we're important
enough now that the post office and
FedEx will come by the office and pick
up from us twice a day
you know your your mentioning the the
3pl on the fulfillment house's I got a
call I don't know if I've ever talked
about this before this is why actually
wasn't a call as an email one of the
less pleasant emails I've ever received
which was I was running my sports
nutrition business way back in the day
thousand years ago it feels like and I
was in Bratislava traveling with two
friends and I was off email for a period
of time as one might expect they read
the first book and I went into my inbox
just to check in for a few minutes and
there was an email from the one of the
managers at the fulfillment center who
said the president or the owner who had
become a friend of mine it's very sad
had died of a heart attack his family
has never wanted to be in this business
and the entire facility is being closed
down you need to have all your inventory
out in the next seven days but I had
received it probably five days after the
email had been sent that was a very
exciting 48 to 72 hours to put it mildly
so yeah there are pros and cons to all
of these different all these different
approaches I knew I knew it wasn't gonna
work out my 3pl when probably a week
after we started with them I was getting
text messages from the fulfillment
center owner he was fulfilling the
orders from cell Ono and he was texting
me photos of products saying is this is
this this it was a disaster yeah yeah
it's they you mentioned the
manufacturing for instance how do you
think about blocking out time for big
picture decisions and product
development and things like that
do you have an approach to blocking that
out in your calendar is it a certain
amount of time you block out each week
how do you how do you think about any of
that because there are the incremental
improvements that can be made yeah we
can improve or we can work with
consultants or people we've hired to
improve let's say paid advertising or
or supply chain or whatever it might be
so these things that you could try to
incrementally improve and then there is
what is the future this business look
like three years from now yeah
how have you approached that so have you
heard of traction by any chance I know
the word traction it's probably another
book there's a book there's also another
one called scaling up by Vern yeah
brilliant you know harness right yes
yeah they're both ways of running our
company I guess the way that traction
explains it is it's you know your phone
has an operating system your computer
does too and so should your business and
we've started working on that a little
bit and they have the this concept of
like rocks and pebbles right
yes and so sand is just like the
incremental stuff pebbles is like a
little more important than that and then
the rocks are like what are the things
that are like really going to make your
business awesome like if you can
implement this stuff where what are the
things that are just gonna make it
really take off and I haven't read the
book but just so people get the visual
the idea being if you have say a mason
jar if you put in the sand first you can
fit in a few pebbles you can definitely
not fit the rocks but if you put the
rocks and first then the pebbles then
the sand fits around it exactly and so
this is something that I've been looking
at for like the last it last month or so
really not that long but I also read a
book called the one thing that has been
really really helpful for me it's I find
that I tend to be pretty scatterbrained
there's always small stuff that I kind
of small stuff pops up on my radar and
I'm like oh I can knock this out like
real quickly and then before you know it
like 40 minutes have gone by and then my
wife wants me to get lunch with her and
then I'm like I have barely even done
anything today I can't like stop and get
lunch right now it's you you're putting
out fires all day and stuff and there
before you know that the days over and
you haven't done anything at all so with
the one thing it's like what's the one
thing that you can do that makes
everything else easier or just entirely
obsolete and so I've been thinking about
that a lot lately like I should really
be manufacturing my own products right
now why because my margins are going to
go
because I'm not as like fragile with my
manufacturers like we had a we had a bug
detector that was mentioned on the Today
Show last November and we sold out of
all our about detectors like instantly
and we couldn't even keep them in stock
for like another three months and I'm
like this is terrible I could have
predicted this
I should be manufacturing my own items
so I've got you know a thousand two
thousand in the warehouse so something
like this happens I can account for it
and I'm not at the mercy of other people
and Alan we're out of the hundred
products which ones how do you know
which ones to manufacture first are they
the ones that sell the most or is there
some other ones that sell the most are
the ones where like I have a have a
vendor that's really unpleasant to deal
with but I have to sell some of the
stuff that they have and so now I'm like
alright how can I cut them out so that's
the first product that I started
developing and then I also have a couple
products that customers have asked for
but I haven't none of my suppliers are
providing it and so I'm like alright
this could be a real opportunity here
and so that's actually going to be one
of the first times that I manufacture
and do you aim for the ones that would
be bought by the enterprise clients I
know you work with some government
claiming we do but most of our customers
are just regular people that have
something going on like then with a
business and something's getting stolen
and they need to find out who or you
know they they're getting political
signs stolen from their yard and they
want to find out who's doing that so all
sorts of like crazy reasons many it's
really hard to find our customers on
Facebook Ads because it's like no
demographic young people who need
surveillance equipment
but um yeah they're just regular people
but we do have like private
investigators and law enforcement so
it's always fun like see an order come
in on the website and it's like from
Department of Justice or something like
that that's always fun
but to get those big orders from them
you have to like do government contract
request for proposals and it's more
involved yeah rfqs and let me think we
get emails all the time from people who
are set up as like government suppliers
I guess
the term yeah they're like yeah we need
mm bug detectors and we need them at
your lowest possible price and then we
get those emails like all at the same
time when you when you made the news the
time that you helped catch the child
molester did that help your sales I mean
what effect does that have so do you
want me to tell the story yeah well
let's yeah I want and tie that into also
the Today Show cuz I'm curious how both
of these things happened but let's talk
about the child predator first okay and
tell us the story of how that happened
all right so and then then to Elaine's
point how if it had an impact on sales
sure so I remember getting a message we
slapped communicate within the team that
I guess that's also a big I remember
getting a message from my employee vents
and he's like hey we had something weird
happened just now and I kind of want to
alert you to it I'm like okay what's up
and he goes we had a live chat come in
and it's from somebody asking about a
particular customer and I told them that
we can't give them any information on
this customer we just just tell you no
random people on live chat about our
customers and what they're ordering I
think that's a good policy so that's
exactly what my employee told the live
chat visitor and then the live chat guy
goes oh okay I am with the District
Attorney's Office and I guess it's
Sherwood our Portland area in Oregon and
we think that this guy I bought a hidden
camera from you and we found this hidden
camera in the boys bathroom of the
Catholic Church where he is a priest and
my employees like okay send us like a
subpoena or a warrant or whatever it is
that they asked for and we can you know
we have to give you that information
and so my employee tells me this and I'm
like oh my gosh this is not what I
needed today and my employee goes I
looked him up and he did buy the hidden
camera from us
and I'm like okay we have to we can't
just like sit on this we have to hand
this information over and so at the time
I was reading trust me I'm lying by Ryan
holiday Ryan there's a lot of Austin's I
am here so that is his first book and it
blew my mind when I read it it's all
about the media and how they work and
how you can use it to your advantage and
then also to your detriment if you don't
play by the rules and I was reading it
at the time and I'm like oh my gosh I
could totally see this headline ending
up on Gawker wait yeah isn't around
anymore but Catholic priest installs
hidden camera in boys bathroom just like
you know screams Gawker and then they
probably mentioned my store or something
like that and then everything I worked
for was gonna be like you know ruined
and so or you'd have a giant influx of
priests as new customers
there's your Facebook advertising I'm
getting so bad and so I'm like okay we
gotta get we got to get the police
department this information they had a
detective that was working the case and
they gave me their contact info and I'm
like okay what can I do what can I do
and so I actually do a Google search for
the guy and I stumble across articles
that have been written about him already
in the local newspaper up there and the
the Oregonian was the name of the paper
and so they already had a reporter that
was on this story and she had come out
with like two to three different blog
posts cuz it turned out that the the kid
like found the camera and then reported
it to his parents who then reported it
to the priest who actually set up the
camera and then he's like oh okay I'll
get this taken care of and then he never
went to the police and so the kids
parents are like what is going on here
and so the police suspected that the
priest was doing something anyways the
the reporter that was working the
article I decided to reach out to her
and I decided to reach out to the
detective that was working the case at
the same time and we kind of worked hand
in hand to get the story out in a way
that looked favorable for me so she you
know the reporter for the paper was
greatly appreciative that I contacted
her with the scoop and allowed me to
share my side of the story and instead
of making it seem like I was an
accomplice to some guy that did like it
terrible we had never even spoken to
this guy he just placed the order on the
website he never called us on the phone
never did a live chat or sent in an
email it's just somebody that placed an
order on the website and did something
terrible
and so I was really worried that that
would just destroy my business and we
worked hand in hand with the police
department they ended up issuing a
warrant for his arrest but he had
already fled the country like a week
prior he went back to the Philippines
while I was from and when the story
finally hit it gave us a lot of
publicity so like all of a sudden other
newspapers were wanting to talk to me
and then TV stations were asking for
like Skype interviews and stuff and it
actually came out on the same day that
Jared from Subway was arrested and that
took up the news for the entire day yeah
also I think Anthony Scalia died the
Supreme Court justice so the news was
just flooded and the story just got
buried but that's it happens what
happens yeah the media the media cycles
and events are never predictable I've
had the great misfortune of in the case
of a few book launches to just get
completely drowned out which which is
always one of those things that can
happen with the Today Show how did that
come about so we would imagine do you
know if anything oh there was not
mentioned specifically but you had the
net to catch the fish on Google right
every week or so there's a story that
comes out about somebody finding a
hidden camera like an Airbnb or
vacation rental and they did a segment
on that and how to find a hidden camera
and so they just generally mentioned a
bug detector and it turns out that like
Amazon like sold out completely and a
lot of customers found our website after
hitting Amazon and not being able to
find anything in stock they came to our
website and purchased all of our
inventory and we were out for months it
was horrible
we had to cancel orders left and right
and it's a difficult time was it more of
a problem than a blessing because some
people this thing might think wow well
you sold out of all your inventory so
that can't be a bad thing but was it was
so was it more do you wish it hadn't
happened would it have been better for
you if it had not happened it was our
biggest sales day of all time and it
still is and so that was really cool at
the moment but then for the three months
after I'm like oh my gosh this is what's
taking so long
factories not being very responsive to
me at all
we have customers calling left and right
and a lot of them we forgot to like
market on orderable on the website so
customer missing orders for it even
though it wasn't in stock and so they
were getting frustrated with us and yeah
it was a difficult time I mean I'm glad
it happened I just wish we had been
prepared better mm-hmm
but you know I'd say 20 20 yeah well the
the mention by the today show is also
one of those be careful what you wish
for not that you were expecting it but
one of those be careful what you wish
for scenarios and certainly back in the
day maybe even still you know Oprah gave
people the hug of death or she would
mention a bakery or company and they
thought it was winning the lottery
ticket the winning lottery ticket but in
fact it just ended up destroying the
business because they would ramp up to
try to do tons of manufacturing or hire
extra people and then a week later they
didn't know how to sew reconcile what
had just happened what are some of the
well we have I think just a little bit
of time left some of the highlights when
you look back and see you you were in
this job
you are underpaid overworked really
hating the nine to five or one of seven
to seven whatever the hours might have
been experienced you start this company
would have been some of the peak
experiences or or things that you
couldn't have imagined would have come
true that you couldn't have imagined at
the time when you were like man if I can
just make thirty grand this will work
out so the first thing that comes to
mind as I look out of this this amazing
view of Austin is that I'm sitting here
chatting with you right now
I mean book was hugely influential to me
and then a lot of my friends so this has
been an awesome experience meeting
people who were like me has been the
biggest impact of my life like I kind of
a through high school just like as a
loner and I didn't really have a lot of
friends and I was kind of like wandering
around aimlessly but starting this
business up has exposed me to people who
are just really cool and really
interesting and if we went to high
school together then we probably would
have like gotten along really well
we've been awesome and so seeking those
people out and finding them and on
Twitter it's easier than ever I can't
remember who said it I want to say it
was an evolved raava calm I think he had
a tweet and he's like Facebook is where
you meet the people of your past and
Twitter's where you meet the people of
your future and I'm like holy crap that
is exactly what's happened to me like
I've met so many amazing people on
Twitter and you can have these great
conversations without having to
physically be near them at all so
meeting people through Twitter meeting
people at these events other business
owners who are just doing really cool
stuff in our into personal development
and fitness and entrepreneurship and
just cool people even
without that stuff like I enjoy being
around them so I've kind of been able to
like find my tribe type of thing I would
imagine you also have quite a few people
who come to you now having seen what
you've done
friends and maybe just people in these
communities who want to get your advice
what do you what do you say to those
people who are maybe where you were some
time ago in the sense that they they
have a job it's paying decently well but
they just dread Monday morning when it
rolls around going back in what do you
say to those people or what advice have
you given them or would you give them so
I actually don't get a whole lot of
people asking for advice I kind of like
lay low I think yeah but the people who
do reach out I give them a handful of
books to read that word usually we
talked about some of them earlier I can
need more later if you want but I tell
them to read these books if they have
any questions they can get back to me I
give them a list of podcasts that I
listen to what are some of those
podcasts so been listener of Tim Ferriss
show for a long time
Tim Tim talk talk I appreciate that
thanks Kevin Rose for making that stick
forever
gotcha I appreciate that
yeah I'm sliding a 20 across the table
we had a deal because I had the time for
this what other podcast ecommerce fuel
ecommerce fuel yes
and then EECOM crew EECOM crews my
favorite ecommerce podcast that's run by
a friend of mine named Mike and he's
been almost completely transparent with
his e-commerce business it's a
seven-figure e-commerce business they do
adult coloring books amazing wait you
don't know I
meaning adult themed content plus
coloring or coloring books for adults
coloring books for adults okay
another growth opportunity when I
started my business a limited number of
colors that you'd be using for the
former brawly's maybe not a good idea
good
so econ crew I would totally suggest to
anybody who wants to start an online
business that's selling physical
products because they talked about
factories finding them work working with
them raising money running an e-commerce
store and like how to do Facebook ads
correctly and like make money from that
it's really cool stuff when I about two
months after I started my business I've
learned about the tropical mba podcast
mmm
again terrible names usually mean that
the products pretty good but these are
guys that do entrepreneurship Tim
Ferriss saw and so they have a lot of
really great episodes with people like
me who are doing maybe they'll do
fulfilled by Amazon businesses so
they'll find products sell them only on
Amazon and then Amazon will actually
ship it for them as well so they never
have to physically handle the inventory
which sounds amazing to me FBA sellers
they interview people who are running
like digital agencies so paid ad
campaigns on like Google or Facebook
Instagram they'll interview people who
have like a small team and they'll be
based like in the Philippines or in
Thailand or something like that running
their business remotely for u.s. clients
and it keeps costs low and they'll share
with you everything that they know like
how they stumbled into that niche so you
hear about people who are doing really
interesting things and niches you've
never known about like the guys that run
that podcast sell valley podiums i love
it
they're like the number one distributor
of valley podiums in the US and so I
remember being in Dallas getting a
haircut a couple months ago and they had
valet parking and I looked down at the
thing and I see their logo on it and I
just
crack-up because these are guys that I
found out about through the podcast who
like lived in Thailand at the time its
immense and people are doing cool stuff
everywhere and plus they're just
invisible stories around you constantly
right saying if you walk into I just
recently learned this like the cardboard
sleeves that hold coffee that you would
get in a coffee shop those called surfs
and there's a guy responsible for the
most dominant surfs the United States or
not too long ago I think it was in Idaho
and I ended up driving by this gigantic
estate this enormous ranch with multiple
buildings and ponds and this and I'm
like who is whose Ranch is that and they
go oh you know those little winglets
that you see on the on the edges of
airplane wings that point upwards like
yeah he's the guy who made those I mean
you just you never quite piece it
together or you wouldn't think of it
unless someone points it out well we're
gonna wrap up in just a few minutes here
but what are you what are you hoping say
next year in the next 12 months there
anything you most want to change or
tackle for yourself could be related to
the business could just be overall but I
mean you have what a lot of people would
see as a dream I mean they you have your
own business you are the the maker of
your own destiny in a lot of senses
you've far surpassed thirty thousand
dollars per year so what what are some
things you're working on you mentioned
personal development it could be with
the business or it could be outside of
the business but what what do you
focused on these days so the thing I'm
on mine right now is I have a kid coming
next month thank you yeah
so I'm kind of interested to see how
this will go with the free time and
being able to work on the business and
so I've really taken upon the task of
building out my team and letting them
carry more of the burden well not a
burden but carry more of the weight yeah
because I can't do everything on my own
anymore it's impossible and by Bill
a team I can have people that I depend
on to actually not just maintain the
business but I want them to help grow it
and figuring that out has been a lot of
fun it's been a lot of you know school
doing stuff on my own for a long time I
mean that's how people typically see it
like when they do entrepreneurship it it
starts out with just them but building
out a team has been like life-changing
for me because they can handle all the
shipping and stuff so I don't have to I
don't have to take a single customer
call anymore if I don't want to
sometimes I'll hear a train and I'll
snatch it before somebody else does but
you know I could go months without
hanging a phone call if I really wanted
to and that that's great
yeah so building out my team figuring
out how to factor in having a newborn
baby in my life I think that's gonna be
really interesting I love meeting other
entrepreneurs and finding opportunities
to you know have great conversations or
like start a business together or help
other people with their businesses I get
a lot of joy out of that and so yeah
I've done the dream lighting thing and
I'm like all right whatever I want to be
a year from now five years from now and
I just really want to be helping people
who were you know maybe where I was when
they were like 18 or 22 or whatever if I
can share some of the knowledge and
point people in the right direction then
I think I get a lot of personal
satisfaction out of that I think you've
done a lot of that today so first and
foremost thank you for taking the time
this has been really fun of course yeah
and Alan where can people find out more
about you websites if they want to ask a
question or or wave low on Twitter or
elsewhere anything anything that you'd
like to share I would suggest against
giving your personal email address
okay so my business website is spy-guy
comm SP ygu wine.com
I'm on Twitter give me a shout it's at
Allen third so a ll e n th I Rd and I
have a personal site as well
there's not a whole lotta on it at the
moment but maybe in the future
Allen Walton comm amazing and Elaine
thank you for being here I know I was I
was charging pretty hard for most of
this interview but I wanted to introduce
you guys to Elaine because I am hoping
to do quite a bit more with you in the
future so this is this is going to be an
experiment as we collaborate via audio
and hopefully in other ways but I think
this was this was a really fun outing
and and Elaine did help with getting me
up to speed on a lot of the basics so
that I could ask questions that were
informed so thank you for that as well
oh thanks him it was great to be here
and it was really great to see how you
looked at Allen's business that was
really fascinating for me well I I'm
hoping that and I'm sure you will and I
know you already are behind the scenes
so we have secrets coming for you guys
but you'll be shedding light for me on
quite a few people and businesses as
well so thank you Alan Thank You Elaine
and to everybody listening thank you for
listening and you can find show notes
links to everything that we discussed in
the show notes as per usual Tim blog a
forward slash podcast and until next
time maybe you should do some fear
setting and dream lining and certainly
think about what experiments you want to
run in the next year until next time bye
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books fresh books has become the go-to
cloud accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advise and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid to track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast the new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free super
easy late payment reminders you don't
have to chase people automatic expenses
sharing files and messages with your
clients
award-winning customer service they are
extremely responsive the interface is
super intuitive and there's almost no
learning curve so in short it's easy it
saves you time and right now fresh books
is offering an unrestricted 30-day free
trial for all of my listeners to claim
yours check it out go to freshbooks
dot-com forward slash Tim and enter Tim
Ferriss in the how did you hear about a
section and that is funky spell TI m fe
r r is s so again they're fresh books
calm forward slash tim and enter tim
ferriss and how did you hear about us
section check it out this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by
the genius Finn's who the internet on
fire and you may have heard there
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which is taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or you need chugga
which is you have a separate version and
I use both of these primarily for focus
and productivity they just get you coin
let you up like a Christmas tree so
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing but I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast your
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters as reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c compote / Tim
and use the code tim TI m to get 20% off
of your first order and they're not that
expensive anyway if you are in the
experimental mindset I do not think
you'll be disappointed to try them up
you
you